right well now we're going to bring it
home and back to the uk for the last the
final part so do stick with us the last
part of the debate and i'm going to
welcome to the stage with me dr pierre
noel who is senior research associate
and director of energy policy forum at
the university of cambridge specializing
in oil and gas markets and industry and
david how lord howe who's an advisor to
the foreign secretary on energy security
and a former minister of state at the
foreign office with responsibility for
international
energy issues uh we'd like to try and
draw together a bit of what we've heard
tonight before the final round of of
questions uh david how i mean from what
you've heard tonight
do you see a major shift in the role of
gas on the questions about gas
well i think i think a lot of it is
is happened already i mean with the
major shift has happened in america the
entire world's
gas or energy mix
is being altered while we're sitting
here all sorts of countries particularly
either side of africa which are very
very concerned with tanzania
mozambique kenya and the other side
sierra leone
um
ghana and nigeria itself are all seeing
fantastically changed prospects now as
they as it turns out that they have got
commercially recoverable
um
shale gas and shell or tight oil as well
um offshore and onshore which is going
to transform their prospects and their
probably and their politics as well so
there's a huge change going on now and
the question for the politicians and the
policymakers is how this is managed in a
sensible way consistent with what is
generally agreed in all parties in and
in government in this country that we
must move towards the low-carbon green
age that we must do it in a sensible way
that we mustn't let the politics screw
up the
the ambitions and the ideals now that
that is the really tricky area this is
almost entirely to do this
this debate with communication with
people
and carrying
uh
democratic political societies in a way
that will
make the aims of low carbon consistent
with economic recovery now and a
reasonable and a reasonable carrying of
burdens but not an unreasonable
accounting burden so that's where we are
now
yeah what questions did the debate throw
up for you tomorrow observations about
the concerns
well you know the the
i think there's a bit of a reality check
to to to be done currently in europe all
over europe gas is displaced
gas consumption is going down everywhere
in all sectors of the economy
if we want more gas to be consumed we
can i mean there's plenty of it
on the market but in europe gas is
squeezed
between renewables that are very heavily
subsidized on the one hand
and coal which is absurdly cheap on the
other hand
um we have so the you know
and and that is squeezed between the two
so one way out which would be sensible
in terms of of of climate change
is to have a carbon price that's a bit
more a bit more reasonable which by
which you would be a bit higher i mean
which would at the very least restore
the competitiveness of gas against coal
um
but the way we subsidize renewables
actually depresses the carbon price in
europe
so we have a set of completely
inconsistent policies
that give us the worst of all worlds
which is the high cost of renewables and
the high emissions of coal
occasionally expressed some frustration
with uh with the green agenda
you put it rather politely saying all
parties you know should uh work towards
carrying a reasonable burden but
sometimes you have suggested that this
burden may be actually rather
unreasonable
well what i'm really saying is that it
doesn't sound too paradoxical is that
the green agenda if pressed
incompetently in political terms with
the wrong compelling messages
imposed on people in the wrong ways will
actually delay the green revolution the
and we just had a perfect example here
that people are saying oh we must be
very careful about gas expansion and uh
we don't shale gas in america is fine
but we don't want to see too much
encouragement here what is the net
effect of that the net effect is that
american coal is pouring into europe
we're burning more coherent in this
country europe's coal as a whole
is increasing the actual germans are
planning new coal-fired
stations with and um co2 while informing
falling to america to the 20 20-year
level
lowest level
uh and have fallen 14 in the last two
years
and the per capita emissions has fallen
dramatically
so it's not just a recession issue well
i don't want to challenge you with that
because you have chosen quite a two-year
horizon in a time of
low u.s growth can i call you on that
well you can call me but the 57 million
extra people in america in the last 20
years and yet the carbon
co2 emissions are now 20 down they are
very low now compared anyway that so the
here's the zealotry of over eager i'm as
green as the next i want to see a low
carbon high efficiency
low intensity density economy but if you
press this too far get the politics
wrong what do you do you create more
pure property which is what we're
happening now with very high gas prices
although we haven't got to this it would
get worse with high if they're
maintained you uh apparently generate
far from lessio to generate more
uh you
damage
competitiveness of industry um you
obviously weaken the growth of jobs and
delay the recovery this seems a very
very expensive
advance a very expensive procedure in
order to
rush through too fast the green
revolution it's a question of pace and
communication that's what it is it's
space communication and politics now
just comment on that if you'd like to
and what was the question again well the
question is i suppose
one do you see it the same way that
david sees it or indeed if you want to
outline something of your uh
your own set of solutions please do that
you know i think there's a
what's happening in the uk is very
interesting
because
you have uh
a situation that's politically very
difficult for for for the government
it would be as difficult if it was the
labour party running the country it's
not a question of parties it's a
question of
the country has committed to some
targets that
guess what are very expensive to reach
and politicians have spent the better
part of the past decade telling people
don't worry it's going to be very cheap
we're going to go green and we're going
to save money at the same time it's
going to be great
and now the invoices are starting to to
come and it's only the very beginning
we've barely scratched the surface
so
i have basically two messages the first
one is
whatever we do on climate change we have
to do it cost effectively we have to
start with the cheapest carbon emission
reductions that we can get
currently we're starting with the most
expensive ones offshore winds is a
typical example
uh solar panels is another typical i
mean
the cost of them is falling quite
quickly we have to be honest but still
very very high
um
that's the first message do it do it
cost effectively the the only way that i
know about to do that is simply to tax
carbon right at the highest level that
the political process will allow
which we may not be very very high
but hopefully we'll be higher than what
we currently have
the second message is
let's be very honest about the long-term
objectives
if we don't have a meaningful global
agreement
that will uh
map a way to share the burden of
addressing this global problem
there will not be
any low carbon system
in any country there will be a lower
carbon system that's pretty cool
compared compared to what we have
because we won't get a global agreed
legally binding system we've tried that
the chinese are not going to touch that
the russians are not going to touch it
the americans are not going to touch it
we trade with all those people that is
the fantasy world but we will get lower
carbon on a substantial scale america is
enjoying it now because at least partly
of the shale gas revolution the switch
from coal to gas which is massive uh
china is actually
although their emissions are very very
high and they're the greater missile
they are applying all kinds of new
energy technologies they're brilliant at
solar reducing the cost of solar so it
may come within reach right so this is
really this is the talk about global
targets you see
is the wrong approach i'm afraid i think
the right approach is technology we have
to apply the technologies to get the
cost of ccs down to get the solar way
way down it can go from can be reduced
by nine tenths in over the next few
years if we really concentrate on
technology and government support for
the technology for green it for green
technologies we will make progress if we
go on about targets and taxes we won't
we'll just get political reaction and
we'll go backwards as we are doing now
let's get a reaction from that yeah i i
entirely agree that uh
spending money on r d is uh is is key to
any any serious energy and climate
policy r d spending on energy has gone
down 80 percent in 30 years
um
so you know this just gives you a bit of
a that's where you should go china and
green energy
china and green energy is is my favorite
one i've got a spreadsheet in my
computer where i track year after year
the percentage of the growth in chinese
energy primary energy consumption that's
covered by coal
and it used to be 98 percent and now
it's 78
and it's going down very slowly so
you know yes i mean they they they send
they manufacture solar panels that they
send to to germany
uh because the german consumers is
apparently very
uh very willing to
to pay uh to transfer subsidies to china
this will stop uh before before we start
doing it in the uk let's bring this back
to shale gas mr liu turning the chinese
energy minister told me the other day in
brussels that um china had a five-year
plan for shale gas so they had more
shell gas than america if they could get
to it he admitted the geological
problems which i some other channelmen
said that is chinese for saying some of
these shale gas deposits are under
cities a little
so so but they have got
if they move that way to shale gas they
will achieve more in terms of reducing
the growth of carbon emissions than uh
anything else than all these other fancy
global
reducing the growth
reducing
that is not going to give you 450 ppm
we are moving towards the end now so i
would love to bring anyone in who just
feels that they've got to ask if you
could make short pointed questions would
be very appreciated the gentleman in the
blue shirt and then
oh gosh so many hands the lady in the
black top and we'll see how far we get
do we have a microphone hello houston
anyone puts a hand up and gets a
microphone go first as far as i'm
concerned go through the lady in the
black top and if you could keep them
really short and also your answers
concise
thank you very much my name is natasha
munier and i work in the investment side
and i'm curious on your views about the
taxation of carbon the current system of
carbon permits is really dysfunctional
it costs very little it's about seven
eight euros a ton and yet if that were
to go up our energy bill would go up too
because it's clearly passed on to the
consumers so it really creates a
conundrum i'm not sure what's best in
terms of carbon reduction and what's
best for the consumers and the
politicians who we vote for hold that
thought we'll take another question over
here yes
do we have a microphone yes thank you uh
benny piser
from the global warming policy
foundation i don't know whether you've
seen the
recent debate between president obama
and
romney
but basically they were vying who would
get more oil and coal and gas out of the
ground
climate change didn't feature but they
they try to portray themselves as
people who would even get more out of
the ground so
i think we need a little bit of a
reality check climate change is dead
internationally
even in europe countries are rolling
back the policies
and it's obvious that the countries in
the next 20 30 years that have the
cheapest form of energy will be the
successful countries and the countries
with the most expensive form of energies
will go down the drain that's the
reality and i wonder whether the penny
is beginning to drop in this country
yes but the cheapest form of energy will
come from those with the cleverest
technology and the greatest efficient
use of energy uh that that's that's
where
it's i come back to the technology point
i mean i i don't quite agree with any
that the climate
debate is dead there are a lot of people
who are rightly concerned that we could
be heading for
great climate violence of an increasing
kind and leading
vast suffering to numbers of people so
that is not the dead there was the
exchange tonight between mitt romney and
uh
barack obama was quite amusing because
mitt romney said about you're not an oil
man when barack obama said well you're
not a gas man
so
it's it's a question of technology i'm
the the the fear i have is that the over
zealotry the people saying no let's push
up the prices let's have carbon permits
so poised that carbon becomes
cripplingly expensive and disincentive
to all gas and everything those who say
never mind about the consumers never
mind about fuel poverty never mind about
industry let's pile on the costs so that
we get a minimum subsidy for renewables
those people are going to wreck the
whole program frankly they're going to
destroy the green programme sorry david
could you possibly take on a bit of the
first question on price yes
well you know uh
the
the problem we have is that the damage
we
cause to the global
environment is not reflected in the
price of the energy we consume right
that's the most basic definition of the
problem we
we have
if you bring even partly
the the the cost the what we call the
external cost of your fossil fuel
consumption into the price of energy you
raised you know the price is a bit
higher or much higher if you do it if
you do it uh meaningfully there's no way
around that yes
addressing climate change is all about
changing the relative prices of energy
to make the carbon intensive ones
relatively more expensive and the carbon
less intensive one relatively less
expensive
actually it's all about what the public
will believe and what they will take in
the way of messaging the public can
believe whatever they want the tone of
co2 in a turn of call
in a democracy it actually matters well
they did that wasn't um
that that wasn't the point that we heard
mike stevenson pointed out that it was a
real problem what the public believed
well and and what he convicted and the
power of those who have got authority on
the eloquence in order to convey the
right message the saving the world
message of alcohol is absolutely
hopeless it is not convincing anybody at
all you know what i thought you probably
wouldn't agree with that
um so let's just try a couple of really
really quick questions towards the end
and then a gentleman could sum up there
was some hands at the back
have they did yes there's a gentleman
here yes please
introduce yourself i want you to just
come back to uh
sorry allen riley city university um
i was gonna ask pierre about
his the issue about china i mean i've
talked to some of the chinese and when
they talk about the scale
of the the resource base in china of
shale gas
they they say yes there are difficulties
but the potential in terms of their own
energy security
um the potential in terms of reducing
not just the co2 issues but the general
terrible levels of pollution from coal
in chinese city the incentives are so
great
that you know the idea of having the
plan which is i think six and a half
billion cubic meters by 2015 100 billion
cubic meters by 2020 and then looking at
something to six to 800 billion cubic
meters by by uh
2030 they see that as potentially
achievable now if they do do that surely
you are talking about something which is
a real blunting of climate change
because at the end of the day right
they're the sharp end of the co2
emissions okay and we have heard from
before so let's have here someone we
haven't heard from before um the
gentleman in the middle with the glasses
could you possibly get the mic in here
please in the middle
thanks my name is archie fraser i'm an
alternative energy
analyst in the city
the speakers have made a couple of
points about the
fall in the cost of solar energy and the
potential
future fall but i wonder if they're
really aware of the scale of what has
happened in solar energy i'd just like
to
chuck three facts at them firstly the
cost of a solar module has fallen 80
percent in the last four years from
about
3 euros
a what to about 60 cents
that's just a question of fact
secondly the amount that you can be paid
in germany for a rooftop system under
the feed-in tariff is now well below
what you actually pay for retail
electricity
so if you choose to buy electricity um
you will pay
about 10
more than the government will pay you
for your rooftop system which shows
pretty clearly that the system uh is
competitive at below the level of retail
cost and thirdly i'd just like to point
out that
several gigawatts of ground mounted
solar systems are currently in
development in spain
um developers are putting in tens
hundreds of millions of cost in
developing several gigawatts of projects
which are not expected or intended to
receive any subsidy at all right so
we've got one china question hang on
your uh solar uh three-pointer
no more three pointers but if anyone's
got one really go on this lady up here
who's got her hand nice and high and it
looks like she's got a very
brief and pointed question my name's
nicola park i'm i work in industrial gas
rather than the natural gas and energy
field but i'm also a stem ambassador and
we talk a lot about technology is going
to be the source i've been to a school
today and lots of these kids are not
interested in in stem subjects but we
need them to come forward in order to
bring these technologies so that we can
solve this problem what do you think we
should be doing about that
right um would you like to take this
steven so i didn't quite get the last
one so it was really about getting it
was your question was how to get
interest across in the new technologies
yeah but actually was an interesting
question because it's come through
tonight a bit of frustration that we
don't win over public support and public
opinion there's no oh i think i think
there's an enormous where are we
starting enormous amount to be done in
schools about the excitement and
possibilities of the new technologies
but they've got to get the cost down
what is what is naughty in the political
world is pretending as i think someone
said earlier in the debate that we can
get to this renewable green low-carbon
world
with less
problems of middle east oil less
problems of digging up the earth and so
on
and can do it in a way that is all very
easy and won't cost a lot of suffering
and difficulty it can be done but it's
got to be done very slowly and carefully
and it is the misleading idea that we
can jump to the low carbon economy
without pain we have said that i think
you should move on and talk just briefly
give a reply on solar if you could i can
give you a very that's what you're
saying is is largely correct and indeed
i alluded to it earlier except i think
it's a night it's fallen by nine times
not eight times in the last uh five
years the solo prospects are great the
chinese have got way ahead in the
technology it is a
very big hope for all the villagers in
desert and poorer areas around the world
a billion and a quarter people haven't
got electricity at all can when they get
onto huge grids very difficult a much
cheaper and possibly a more exciting way
is really efficient and low-cost pvcs
for low-cost solar development it's full
of potential it's very exciting but it
all comes down to cost and the chinese
are leading the way on that and weld on
them let's have pierre
no well the cost of solar is going down
i mean
fantastic it's uh
uh
it's great i mean i mean again if we if
if the cost of plea of of
clean
heat and electricity
doesn't fall down dramatically
we're not going to solve this problem
right
because we're never going to impose on
ourselves the types of carbon prices we
would need to address it meaningfully
right so the cost of solar has gone down
fantastic
the bill has been extremely high for
those who have actually pump primed this
market
just
last year
the total amount of green energy i mean
of renewable energy subsidies in germany
was 17 billion euro a year
it's going to be nearly 20 more than
that this year and it's a it's for 25
years right
17 billion euros a year
uh just to give you a point of
comparison
abu dhabi bought six gigawatts of
nuclear power from the south koreans for
5.6 billion euros and it's that
dispatchable zero carbon power
so the germans have paid for bringing
them down the cost of solar
not by actually improving the technology
at all just bringing the chinese in
that's right and now they're asking the
rest of us france the uk
to support them in an antitrust case
against china i mean
you know that's right
you mentioned spain okay
so now that the cost has gone down
perhaps that they need less subsidies or
maybe no subsidies at all which is great
which is great and i agree with you
but the past 10 years
the the the the uh
the government in spain has refused for
the cost of renewables to be reflected
in the tariff
so what they did is they created this
huge debt
which guess what
they securitized
so they created a new junk bond which is
implicitly granted by the germans
because it's in the eurozone
well that you can buy if you want to
you're in the city you can buy it
what could possibly go wrong if we give
you tons
these are all the problems these are all
the problems if you go the wrong way
which we've been going in many areas of
attempting to subsidize renewables the
future if we want to get co2 down it's
got to be step by step it's got to be
politically practical it's got to base
for the mean
and
technology relations
gas and texas
yeah yeah yeah so not everything else
you said
you've said time and again it's all
about technology technology technology
the cost the cost has has to go down
it's not going down magically it's good
and if you throw money at it
lots of money at it who pays for that
the cost of technology is not going to
go down like that so we go you know we
we cannot go around the problem this is
a serious policy problem because it's
very expensive chinese technology is
bringing down the price and there are
many other areas where we can get the
price down i agree needs government
support that's absolutely right but it's
much better spending money that way than
subsidizing useless wind farms and
offshore farms which are wireless but
this is simply that better three seconds
to finish your point you all need to go
and have some dinner it is very heavy
german subsidies for solar that brought
the chinese in and the price is down
it's not magic
it's technology it's not magic at all
but
but i do hope that we have generated at
least a bit of light as well as rather a
lot of heat particularly at the end of
our debate tonight
look thanks to all of our speakers and
of course to intelligent squad and shell
for hosting this event which i've
certainly enjoyed very much and hope you
have um we would be very grateful if you
could fill in the feedback forms which
are on your chairs or probably under
your chairs by now if you got agitated
and kick them out of the way and thank
you all so much for coming safe journey
home
you